my name's Barry seal that's for the
damage for your sister hey little
darling and you're back some of this
[ __ ] really happened okay so first of
all you are known for the movie run
you've perfected it in this is it the
biking the children's biking is that
gonna be your new trainee the bicycle
was incredible working with Tom it's not
least he's incredible performer but like
he comes up with these ideas right in
the moment it could be very stressful
working with the pair of them because
they change everything and you can get
really down on yourself with that stuff
if you let yourself and then you realize
no this is part of the process you know
this is part of the process you just
gonna have fun with them is it gonna be
good for us you trust me
Oh - you did it feel more like very very
structured or did it feel sort of like
anything can happen well we had this
time where we were able to like rehearse
and sort of play around with it but
absolutely every time you got to set
like whatever was on the page we were
gonna do that and we were gonna do
version so that I come from a comedy
background so for comedy and television
like things are always changing so for
me that was super I can totally go with
that we need you to deliver stuff for us
oh this is legal if you're doing it for
the good guys
was the mooning your idea that was
Doug's that was burning I mean it really
is Barry seal we have real foot I mean
so that's he was a thing he always did
you know it was it was his actual no
black double no yeah I just don't know
what happens when you say that Tom
Cruise you're like you know we've worked
together and we've really come to a
working relationship but still I'm like
how do you ask him how do you enter out
so how do you prepare for something like
that you do all your own stunts so you
had your but double no stunts oh no you
just you don't think about it you just
do I was working for the CIA the DEA and
Pablo Escobar leukemia and tuscaloosa
that's 15 like the owner killers are in
one go get it done
you